here's what would happen if our oceans  froze if more than half of the Earth was  covered with ice the Earth would reflect  enormous amounts of sunlight this would  disrupt the planet's water cycle Earth  would become as dry as the South Pole or  even parts of the Sahara the oceans  freezing over would likely mean mass  extinction of many species of animal  without Fish seafood would no longer be  a reliable staple of many diets oceans  specifically phytoplankton produce  between 50 to 85 percent of the oxygen  in our atmosphere billions of people and  animals would suffocate if you manage to  be one of the very few survivors  eventually oxygen levels could normalize  once again but sadly you'd no longer  experience the calming effect of looking  out at the water  so